this is where is her children are
staying they had to flee Khartoum
immediately after fighting broke out
there in April
arriving in Port Sudan they were offered
shelter in this unfinished building
along with half a dozen other families
but overcrowding excessive summer heat
and lack of basic sanitation inside the
building forced them out into the
streets
our main problem here is the lack of
food Aid agencies bring some but not
regularly they haven't brought anything
for about a month the second problem is
shelter as you can see we have to see in
the open with children and the elderly
some of whom are sick
this woman says she has cancer and
desperately needs immediate care
it's been a month now since we started
to really suffer there is no food even
though the people of Port Sudan have
been generous to us we can't thank them
enough in another Street we meet this
family they're literally homeless
10 days ago the center has refused to
give us a place inside saying its fault
it's the responsibility of the U.N but
where's the UN
U.N officials agree that help should
reach everyone those people in Khartoum
those people in Darfur are facing
significant challenges but I should also
say that amongst the displaced in the
East and in the South they are living in
gathering sites they are living in host
communities and the needs are enormous
enormous needs for medication enormous
needs for for food for water and
sanitation and also malnutrition and
nutrition supplies
for those needs to be met the U.N says
urgent funding from International donors
is needed as well as immediate access by
local authorities
and the condition for all of that is a
real ceasefire that can last Muhammad
al-jazeera Port Sudan